our eyes naturally follow patterns when
we look at things we usually start in
the top left and then we'll look from
left to right and then top to bottom
traditional print media takes advantage
of the patterns our eyes follow and so
do websites for instance with our
website here we have the title at the
top because we want the title to be the
first thing that people see when they
click on our website after they get past
the title they'll move down and at the
left we have images these images are
here to capture attention because people
will look at the images first then
they'll see the headline and then once
they read the headline they'll go down
to the text below it this type of design
follows what we call the grid base
layout and in fact many if not all web
sites follow a grid-based layout here we
are on the Udacity courses page it's
pretty easy to pick out the grid on this
page we can see that there's a main
column on the Left that's broken into
smaller grids and then on the right we
have this large column that's broken
into smaller grids in fact we can keep
breaking it down into smaller and
smaller grids other websites like the
New York Times do the same thing it's
pretty easy to see how the New York
Times is broken into grids and we can
keep going breaking it into smaller and
smaller pieces of the grid next time
you're on a website try to break it
apart into grids you'll be surprised how
easy it is